grant cardone is the best-selling author
of the 10x rule and forbes called him
the number one
marketer to watch he went from being a
kid labeled with add
almost dying of a drug overdose to
becoming a real estate mogul with a
portfolio
of 1.5 billion dollars
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one keep
working on yourself people got to keep
working on themselves yeah
you're trying new things you got to give
something up like i'm
always giving stuff up my life changed
when i gave stuff up when i was 25 and i
gave drugs up i'm like okay i'm done
and then you give up your friends right
because when you start changing
they're gonna go people don't like it
they're to go or you're going to come
back
and if you're not i i truly believe that
if you're not changing your friends
you're not changing
your friends should be you're they
should be like every few years a cycle
yeah or they should be changing growing
with you they're not going to grow with
you
really well i hope you'll grow later i
hope i'm friends with you in 10 years
yeah but we will be yeah we will be you
know but
but like i know i know i dated this girl
her
friends were her childhood friends
she never changed yeah it's tough none
of them changed
the whole group never changed like for
me to change you can't
i can't think of me and your best
friends that me and you're going to have
we're going to change at the same time
we have different reasons to change
throughout life right right and
and elena and i we'll we'll have
different times when we want to change
my kids like
my kids are going to change and they're
going to leave
100 they're going to leave i don't want
to do this anymore right
they're going to go flying private back
to flying commercial
yeah until they touch yeah until they
figure out how to fly
private if if they even want to do that
yeah but but i've always said i've
changed so many times i've moved i've
been five or six different cities that's
been great for me every
every move has been better for me i've
changed friends i've had lifelong
friends that
i know him but you're not hanging out
every day no i moved on
rule number two believe when i was a kid
glenn i was like i knew i was gonna do
something great
and had zero reason to believe that
right like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not i think everybody has that
i would imagine that every kid
um has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother
uh he he would he'd be in the mirror man
he's like eight years old we're eight
years old he's singing
in the mirror like he's a rock star
right i had to listen
to that all the time and and then i
start thinking
man man if he's going to be a rock star
he's going to go on and be a big rock
star
and and and i can't you know because i
that
that that wasn't my deal i said what am
i gonna be
and then i thought i'm gonna be a
baseball player i actually
believed i was gonna be a baseball
player right dude i wasn't fast enough i
wasn't smart enough
i didn't have the arm i mean i had no
talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man you're you're
thinking too small when i
talk to people about real estate don't
do two units
got to start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32. right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too
sure if if you can just believe that you
can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now where there's going
to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone
rule number three take risks what's your
attitude to fear and risk
uh yeah you got it you got you got it
you got it you gotta you gotta take risk
the the the best way to stay out of
harm's way is to be the most dangerous
person in the room
right i like that you know yeah like
yeah do you ever though sometimes think
man i'm taking two big risks every scary
every deal i do yeah every deal it did
make you feel alive
no i know i'm alive i i just i just um
you know like when you take on an arena
and you're like i'm gonna book there's 5
thousand people here
okay my my my gig
did had seven times that many people 35
000 people
yeah i mean i sold out an arena as big
as jay-z and beyonce would sell out
the difference is i had them there for
three days they have them there for two
hours
on super bowl weekend our biggest
football you know you guys
laugh at our football but we love it
right so so
the biggest sports weekend
in the united states of america super
bowl weekend i held my event on that
weekend
freaking insane rule number four take
responsibility
i know a year ago the last time i was on
this interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly
you didn't want to do it you were
struggling dude my ankles hurt my knees
hurt my back hurt my
like like i had constant pain in my body
why'd you keep doing it doing what
working out
no that that that's no that i wasn't
working before you started working my
body was you were in pain i wasn't using
my body
i didn't use it and it started to
abandon me like i wasn't paying
attention to it you know and it's like
okay
dude you know you don't want to pay
attention to me
i'm going to make you pay me i don't pay
attention to you you know
or maybe i'll make you pay attention to
me yeah and then i got
i went to a pt uh three days a week
that really didn't do anything and i
said you know what i need to take
responsibility for this if i want to fix
something
that that that's the code of my life do
you want to fix something
take responsibility yeah do you take
responsive don't give it over to the
physical therapist the masseuse i was
trying the masseuse the masseuse never
helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i hired a guy named anthony he came
i said you come to the you come to my
place every day
same time every day here's the money
here take the money
here's the schedule i'm never going to
miss a day wow
he travels with you two or no no no this
was in the first year
got it and um
you know it's been 14 months i have
almost
zero pain in my body hey man everybody
how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five move with speed
and certainty i had a guy the other day
asked me for some advice
okay you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know
you give it to them and they they don't
do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him he's like
i know that's right and then he went and
did something different
this is a big mistake people make man
things the best things that have
happened to me
did not require any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her
because that adds thought it adds time
and and this is another bad piece of
advice i was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast and and the faster you
can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air when it's landing slowing down is in
trouble when it's taken off it's it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the safest
that thing wants to fly you know and and
people
people are being conditioned to slow
down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20
29 years old because the the
psychologist thought
i needed to slow down she was scared of
speed
i wasn't and at that time were you doing
well financially or
doing i was doing great but everybody
was saying hey you're doing too much of
this and you're doing too much of that
and you're going to burn and you're
going to do this
and people were worried about me around
me they were going slow i was vibrating
faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate
right they do things that are impossible
so
you don't want to slow down and and you
want to move with speed and certainty
that means people need to know what
they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today
talking one today he'd been fighting man
been efforting 10 years he hadn't had a
win he won today
that guy moves with speed and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainty because they practice they
train they educate
rule number six be a student of
observation
i'm a student of observation i i
observed things i remember being
being selling cars saying this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right the
customer
the 12 steps right and then i'm like if
i do 12 steps with everybody i can't get
30 units a month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those 10 car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had
what they what they were going to ask me
for anyway right
can i get you a price a payment a down
payment a monthly bank can i get you
everything you need
right i knew that it was just a matter
of about 30 seconds they were going to
ask for it all
no doubt so i just basically intercepted
the customer
sped up the processes and and then i'm
like man i i started hitting 30 36 units
31 units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it
and then when i lost my job because the
dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
i went out and started teaching that
rule number seven set
correct goals what would you say is the
best advice that you could give other
people from what you learned about
making their first million bucks
so say somebody's making six figures
scaling up and that's just do the math
you know what's what's first of all do
you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal you want to make
everybody's go everybody watching is
going to make a million dollars i mean
if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks
bang you made a million dollars if
that's your goal so
that this is what i talked about in the
10x rule the goals people are setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because i know so many guys that hit a
million dollars
like i've had so many people come to me
and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice it got comfortable
almost yeah a lot of guys in network
marketing tell me this
like i was in network marketing i became
a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal anybody's got a million
dollar target it's not your goal
you adopted this goal this idea from
somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept
you just adopted somebody else's idea i
want to be a millionaire
would do you have even done the math do
the math on a million dollars it's no
money
this is what people they they like god
hate grant
because your target was a million you're
struggling making 200.
you think a million's impossible you
don't want me to tell you the truth and
the truth is it
is no money as soon as you get it i read
the book the millionaire next door
almost everybody read that book back in
the
90s it was the best book for me
because it taught me i don't want to be
a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man right
i got to buy a ford truck a used ford
truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire yeah
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died
at 52 with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die with
money when i'm old i want to have enough
money
and that that un did everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
hit a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on
what their spending is or what their
apartment costs or what the mortgage is
rather or what their kids need rather
than i want freedom
i don't want financial literacy i want
financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need
how much you know this whole cash flow
thing that i talk about all the time
cash flow is the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number
rule number eight
try a plant-based diet two weeks ago i
went
i went uh plant-only plant-based
plant-based i thought i dropped the meat
dude that's so i want to do i did that
for a week
last week yeah and i felt amazing i had
a lot of more gas
just from all the plants i think but
just cleaning it out that's really too
much information for me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation less pain
yeah i hadn't noticed i have a little
bit of inflammation in in my hands but
that hadn't hadn't changed but the
plant-based thing
i watched the game the the game changing
show yeah
and uh when he said dude you're eating
the middleman
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middleman you're
eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like i need
that was the line in the show that did
me and i had been thinking about it too
i've eaten meat for 60 years
i grew up on bacon four pieces of bacon
every day so good
uh oh yeah totally the eggs i
i have not eaten any meat in
12 days and my energy
is freaking this
all day long wow 3 30 in the afternoon
for the last
25 years i crash at 3 30. hard crash i
mean like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what you doing 3 30. i got him i got a
meeting
yeah that meeting was on that nap dude
and when i hit it
i'm talking coma deep
sleep better than sleep at night
sometimes it would be 30 minutes
sometimes it'd be an hour and a half
like comatose 12 days i can't take a nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
it's how good my energy do you think
you're gonna stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes you
think i mean
i'm not i'm not like i'm not a fanatic
guys so yeah so so
there's a little meat here and there or
something i'm just gonna eat what makes
me feel best
yeah so i don't care if it was meat if
it was
pork it was bacon but right now
um as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't met i haven't missed the
meat wow
my digestion's better you know my
freaking great so i don't know man
rule number nine do what your
competitors can't do
our goal at the 10x growth conference
and all the events i do even the free
events i do around we're going to do 50
free events this year
that's crazy man and uh the reason i'm
doing that is because i know guys that i
don't like
can't do it yeah like you go try to do a
free event
right people
gonna bleed out dude i'll bleed the guy
out that's the proper way to use money
by the way
this is straight out of it if you're not
first your last you know do what your
competition
cannot do and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
collaborate the fastest way to grow a
business is to collaborate with other
people
is to find uh these fairies that are
going back and forth b-roll
okay uh the ferries uh dude i i mean i
could build a boat
or i could just go right on one of those
exactly right and
what what we're doing today is we are
drafting or just collaborating with
yeah um cardone capital
i don't go build apartments no i buy
apartments that are already built
that way i can scale faster if i if i
was trying to do the building thing now
construction teams right um
now along the way i'm fixing i'm
adjusting as i go
but but i need to get in the water start
swimming in some direction i think
too many people are trying to figure out
where they're going yeah
and by the time you figure it out
somebody's already there now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below
write down your single biggest takeaway
as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
i've been told by numerous people i'm
going to burn out i've been told that
since i was 26 years old
you're going to burn out and here i am
you know 34 years later i hadn't burned
out
have more energy today than i had when i
was 26
i'm not a candle i'm a spiritual being
spiritual being in their perfect
condition
would not be interested in imbalance it
would be unnecessary
so like nature it's in a state of flow
almost the spirit the spirit itself
would be able to move into any space at
any time
without any gimmicks without any
preparation
uh and and be able to to assist in the
the next emergency you know i see first
responders first responders
these heroes that jump into situations
they didn't know there was going to be a
fire they didn't know there was going to
be a 911 they didn't know that
a kid was gonna be trapped in a car they
move into an event
to save a situation and and uh that's
what i hear ed saying like
he he moves into whatever needs to move
in a very very
very much like a liquid wood mercurial
to be mobile you know to be able to be
able to move into
different things this is why financial
uh freedom is so important for people
and it's it's why cash flow is so
important so that people can move to
their parents and help them
move to a kid in their community that
needs help
and and that's why i pushed that money
message so much because
when you have enough money balance is
not what you're seeking
contribution and charity
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out continue to believe
and i'll see you there